jean casanova consultant en stratégie et
communication bonsoir gilles casanova
quel est votre regard de communiquant
sur ce qui se passe en ce moment à
l'assemblée nationale on arrive
clairement pas à débattre
on est dans une situation très inédite
qui est l' addition de phénomènes qui se
sont déjà produits dans d'autres
séquences politiques dans les 50
dernières années mais qui ne se sont pas
produits au même moment et là ils se
produisent au même moment
donc nous avons un télescopage de la
faiblesse de la crédibilité de
l'exécutif et de ses responsables avec
des affaires personnelles qui prennent
des allures parfois cocasses qui
conduisent l'opinion à un regard
distancié
nous avons un projet qui est
profondément un complet surtout un
projet qui dans sa présentation de
départ est inverse entre le président et
le premier ministre
le président a dit nous faisons une
réforme de justice
à périmètre financier strictement égal
et le premier ministre dit nous faisons
une réforme pour économiser
c'était vraiment l air à du tout la même
chose donc on ne sait pas au parlement
si ce sera une situation où l'autre
puisqu'on ne connaît pas la valeur du
point est que c'est la valeur du point
qui fait là référence d'ensemble qui
fera qu on économisera ou qu on
économisera pas ensuite en fonction des
protestations des professions entières
sont les unes après les autres
retirer de cette réforme qui devrait
apporter tant de bienfaits
selon un exécutif qui retire
régulièrement des professions leur
disant voyez on est gentil avec vous on
vous retire donc le bienfait là aussi le
discours est parfaitement contradictoire
on ne peut pas dire c'est un bienfait et
regardez comme on vous aimons vous des
dispenses de ses bienfaits donc il y à
une situation qui est fermée de
l'intérieur
oui alors elle est fermée c'est vrai
mais à ce que ces quarante mille
amendements est ce que c'est vraiment la
solution pour justement ouvrir ouvrir le
débat et tenter de comprendre vraiment
en parlant du concret là le débat est
obstruée est bloqué il ya ce risque du
49 3 est-ce qu'on va vraiment dans la
bonne direction pour pour tenter de
mieux comprendre cette réforme la
tradition des amendements de masse elle
a été pratiquée par tous les opposants
de droite ou de gauche dans les 30
dernières années
est ce que c'est pour autant la solution
est que ce soit elle permet aux débats
de prendre un peu plus de temps comme il
prend un peu plus de temps à l'assemblée
nationale il prend un peu plus de temps
sur les antennes de télévision et de
radio et dans les journaux et donc il
prend un peu plus de temps auprès de
l'opinion qui a le temps de découvrir un
certain nombre d'éléments et
éventuellement de modifier son attitude
ainsi on a vu par exemple si on peuvent
prendre le mariage pour tous qui a été
l'objet d'un marathon parlementaire
comparables cette fois de la droite on
l'a commencée dans une situation où la
proposition de mariage pour tous avait
une sympathie dans l'opinion de l'ordre
de 66 à 67 % et on a terminé au moment
du vote avec une sympathie à parts
égales pour les défenseurs et pour les
opposants donc on voit que ce processus
permet de dynamiser le débat dans la
société
pas vraiment de le faire avancer au
parlement mais là on l'espèce gilles
casanova n'y a pas de le risque quand
même de pousser le gouvernement
directement vers le 49 3 et donc le
passage en force et de se retrouver
privés de tout démarre pour le coup et
de toute adhésion et de tentative de
compréhension
ce projet le conseil d'état a averti le
gouvernement de l'insécurité juridique
de sa réforme si elle devait être voté
par le 49 3 c'est-à-dire sans débat on
on peut penser que le conseil
constitutionnel réagir est très
négativement
est ce que vous croyez à ces perfides
l'opposition pour tenter cette stratégie
justement pour fausser pousser à la
faute ce gouvernement c'est ce qu'on
entend ici ou là y compris par les
observateurs et les analyses de gauche
on peut penser que l'opposition essaye
de faire comprendre au gouvernement
qu'il n'y a pas de honte à remettre
l'ouvragé sur le métier un peu plus tard
quand de manière évidente personne ne
comprend exactement ce que dit cette
réforme puisque le président maintient
que 7 à périmètre financier constant et
le premier ministre et son ministre des
finances que c'est une mesure d'économie
très importante donc ya là une
distorsion dans l'exécutif même qui fait
que
il y a quelque chose qui devrait bouger
sous une forme ou sous une autre
même si on sait que le président de la
cre on m a avoué qu'il a fait une erreur
puisqu'il n'en fait jamais séoul écoute
alors la mobilisation elle en tout cas
elle se poursuit un peu moins
aujourd'hui sur le terrain en même temps
donnant plein milieu des vacances
scolaires 50000 personnes à paris 92
mille manifestants dans toute la france
1 selon la cgt beaucoup moins évidemment
toujours selon le ministère de
l'intérieur à ce que c'est pas une
aubaine pour le gouvernement de se dire
voilà la mobilisation se tasse sur le
terrain et de poursuivre son entêtement
à passer cette réforme
pas vraiment parce qu'on n'est pas sur
une réforme et qui toucheraient une
question immédiate dont la conclusion se
ferait sur les semaines et les mois qui
viennent on est sur une réforme qui joue
sur les vingt dernières années de la vie
de
la majorité des citoyens qui sont sous
une forme ou sous une autre salariée
haut fonctionnaire donc c'est un enjeu
de très longues distances pour eux et
donc on peut imaginer qu'il y ait une
lui comme pour les gilets jaunes une
longue distance dans la sensibilisation
et la mobilisation et le fait que les
propositions gouvernementales ne sont
pas très claires ne donne pas le
sentiment même si les manifestations
sont tantôt moins élevé et un taux plus
élevé en nombre elles sont de plus en
plus élevés dans les petites localités
et de moins en moins dans les métropoles
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'il va
conduire ce mouvement à s'arrêter
la dernière petite question raconte
parce qu'on arrive au bout la sphère
griveaux évidemment où vous savez suivi
vous aussi comme tout le monde les
députés traité de je cite petite conne
des noms d'oiseaux à l'assemblée c'est
un climat de violence inédit la russie
on a vu des affaires un peu limite mais
pas en même temps que d'autres crises
c'est l'addition de toutes les crises à
la fois qui conduit l'actuel exécutif
dans une situation très peu enviable
merci gilles casanova d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france pers